it's very interesting seeing the quote
unquote red pill World clashing with the
traditional conservative world right
yeah that happened the last few weeks
between the daily wire guys and the Mana
swamp right yeah so so that's
interesting because people are talking
about the I mean the fact that you're
going on Twitter and you're kind of just
seeing like normal people even using the
term red pill right or they're talking
about it like it's a brand new thing
that just started up last year meanwhile
I mean man I I would you consider
yourself red pilled that's a great
question that's a great question
um would do you I mean if you mean red
pill aware then
absolutely if you mean red pill aware if
you mean do I totally subscribe to all
of the thoughts and ideas and
conclusions that some people now called
red pill then then no um so there's a
difference red pilled and red pillow
aare I I think so yeah I think so I
think some when some people talk about
red pill and rightly or wrongly I I
don't think that um you know perhaps
when the coin was termed by Rolo tomasi
or whoever else sort of popularized the
term I I don't think the goal of it
necessarily was for it to be sort of
considered an ideology and a belief
system but I think we can also see that
at least for some people it's sort of
morphed into that where it's like this
whole basket whole basket of ideas not
just the analysis but also the
conclusion right so I think that most of
the red pill analysis not all of it but
I think most of it is accurate right if
you're talking about male nature if
you're talking about female nature if
you're talking about some of the
modern-day challenges and just the way
that the dating markets works or you're
talking about you know sexual
Marketplace value or whatever right some
people might not like these terms or
whatever it is but I think the general
analysis is is accurate right yeah um
but then when it comes to the
conclusion I mean I think the original
version of red pill kind of didn't
really have a conclusion I think it was
just like okay these are things you
should be aware of these are some facts
and yeah here are some facts whereas now
yeah I think that's why you're getting
this clash with the sort of traditional
conservatives because that these are
both being seen as ideologies and the
question is yeah it's about the analysis
but I think the Clash is more about the
conclusions like okay here are the facts
here's the data here's the information
now where do you go from here to me blue
pill is like I mean just not even being
aware of any of this stuff right like
not you you a blue pill person can't
really have this conversation because
they don't even know what the term they
they've just never even thought about
this they don't have the awareness and
all of that and by the
way there is something um there there is
something kind of nice and appealing
about that what's that right you know
how it is as in you know the statement
there's a cliche statement right
ignorance is bliss and there is truth to
that right there is truth like when you
understand how certain things in the
world work whether it's uh male female
relationships and what can happen with
those or it's how the how the government
is really operating or yeah I mean you
can't enjoy music the same way that you
used to you know when you get red pilled
I guess because then you start hearing
songs it's like put her up on a pedestal
and love her forever and you
know yeah exactly right so so there's
something about there's something
sometimes I listen to the lyrics of my
older music that I used to listen to
when I was a teenager like the Rock and
the heavy metal it's like oh here comes
the ballad with that you know pining for
you know whatever well I was mostly A
hip-hop fan so if anything it was kind
of more the opposite but yeah yeah like
hip-hop was more of like you know
hardcore like don't trust
her you yeah there there's there's some
balance to be had there so yeah I mean I
I don't love to apply labels to myself
you know I even get people are you a
liberal are you a conservative are you
you know libertarian and I don't mind
being I don't mind like if someone said
oh you know Zubie's red pilled I don't
take any offense to that if someone's
like oh you're a Libertarian or you're a
conservative or you're a classical
liberal what I'm like cool if if it
makes it easier for you to sort of see
me that way then fine but don't think
that I'm going to sort of completely
subscribe to a single tribe and just
sort of play to that crowd and not say
what I genuinely believe to be true but
like I said all these pills got white
pill black pill purple pill red pill
blue pill uh green pills orange pills
God pill purple pill which one's green
pill I don't I don't know green pill I
think green pill what's green pill I
know something to do with some religion
I've lost track there's so many of them
it's just oh green green pill is Islam
right Islam yeah maybe yeah so I just
get like I just push it all away it's
like look man there's there's what I
know to be the truth and what I know to
be lies and that's what plugged in
versus unplugged is and it's as simple
as that for me I don't want to keep all
your pills like what do you think of
this pill
story I I don't mind I don't care I
think it's kind of funny um
I I think I think it's a little bit
funny like because it's become a bit of
a parody of itself it is right it's like
whatever you ego investing you have a
pill or you'll go make up a new color of
something and stick it on a pill and say
here take this it'll solve your problems
yeah so I don't know I don't I don't
think about it that deeply but um you
know orange pill obviously is like
Bitcoin Bitcoin yeah um yeah blue pill
red pill we've discussed white pill is
like you know hope yeah uh black black
pill is the sort of Doomer mentality
like theism yeah yeah nism um yeah I
don't I don't know I think there's one
group of guys that I just don't connect
with it's the whole victim mindset like
my life sucks there's nothing I can do
about it there's only so much money out
there all the rich people have it I just
want to be basic and average you know
why even bother with women if they're
going to potentially do this if you
don't do that or if you lose your
success and they're going to walk off on
you and bang chat thundercock and it's
like you know like the nihilism it's
like I don't know man because you know I
came from this like upbringing childhood
where was like I was a skinny bucktooth
you know kid that just liked heavy metal
with long hair and I just always knew
that I'd like Fast Cars and cool stuff
and it you know like it required some
competency skills and you know be able
to solve problems so I you know I leaned
into that because I wanted those things
and I always find it strange today when
people you know it's like no I'm going
to put my feet up and uh you know we're
going to call it uh you know giving up
or we're going to call it forget it it's
not worth my time I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clip's from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out